I reply I'm doing a spoiler topper we're
gonna do a spoiler talk anyway Craig
Johnny she didn't why are you gonna run
okay so the moment where everyone
grossed out was the bow where he got the
what was that called that he uses
totally sperm out of the turkey baster
the turkey baster and then he and that
she shoves it in his mouth
yeah there's a whole setup of leading to
that moment is great to me yeah because
you got these characters so we're doing
a bad thing they're dead they're about
to steal a lot of [ __ ] money from a
guy they're doing a vastest daughter you
know like and they're also doing a less
smart version of the bad thing they have
like a bigger wrist bigger reward but
also much bigger risk you know they're
involving guns and money yeah exactly
it's it's it's not a smart decision and
halfway through the film we find out
that this guy is an even worse person
who kind of deserves this little yes you
can make a movie just about what
happened before this yeah it's a weird
10 Cloverfield Lane style movie about
Stephen Lang and the girl in his
basement and I feel like the writers
probably did and some white like I feel
like they had a whole like or at least
even like brother created his own
backstory
definitely put that on screen it does
have that effect bad versus worse
because the when he's worse you're like
he really is worse
so he first shoots dan salvato it's like
yeah it kind of makes sense broke into
his house and held a gun up and we go
point like maybe he stole your money
can't let him get away that happened so
I'm not like a bad guy you are scared
for these guys cuz you care about them
but when you see that he is worse it's
it's a rewarding moment what he twins
when Jane levy gets to do that to him
because the whole time I'm trying to
take down this like [ __ ] blind
Michael Myers dude it just doesn't go
the [ __ ] down like a props to the riding
on knowing how to top rape well that's a
really tense that's an interesting scene
because yeah the first thing you think
is oh my god he's a rape but this is
this is so twisted and [ __ ] up and
then they acknowledge it yeah I'm not
but but the idea of what he wants to do
why imprison you as as the woman
carrying his child and like his whole
goal is just to get you pregnant and
like that's so deserving you know it's a
weird [ __ ] up bounce like you took my
daughter so you're gonna give me a new
one and then you can live the rest of
your life and it's like I get how in
some version of your mind you think this
is a suitable punishment but what the
[ __ ] dude this is so twisted in the
movie toys without really well yes when
when the girl it gets killer shoots the
girl the first girl and then she dies
he's holding her at first you're kind of
wondering like wait you're like
wondering why is he crying yeah it's um
one of these what the [ __ ] my way
through your leg like why is he so mad
oh is he crying yeah exactly exactly she
not dead like so it's very clever when
they do the reveal and the reveal is
really sick and twisted there's there's
something like especially just like yeah
the guy wanted to like rape her and then
impregnate her like yet really
disturbing but there's something that
was more sinister than this specific
story that adds to the fact that he has
no interest in actually penetrating her
he just wants her pregnant with his
sperm yes like there's something really
and like to keep her hostage oh yeah
really really twisted and it's all the
more rewarding when you know like when
when Jane levy essentially just shoves a
dick in his mouth you know and then
sprays it yeah so it's like it's it's
gross its disgusting but it is rewarding
yeah it's like [ __ ] you you guys like
[ __ ] deserved it like that is the one
nasty cruel thing that happens in that
movie where I'm like [ __ ] go girl
[ __ ] do is he seemed like he was
prepped that the first girl was pregnant
it seems like he already like kidnapped
one got her got her pregnant hostage and
I killed her well that's and he was
about to kill about the rape or whatever
it is it's a call artificially
inseminate yeah which is yeah it's just
such a disturbing way like when he cuts
her pants open and like yeah that movie
and they shoot that
completely uncomfortably and and what I
do appreciate about that moment is I
don't feel like this movie wasn't lurid
about it it wasn't moogly it wasn't like
ah it's also sexy it's like mineral this
is just uncomfortable and yet tense and
ugly it's still a really disturbing
scene even though Jane let me ended up
totally okay is gonna [ __ ] that woman
over but I have to live with that memory
forever and like I can't imagine what
that would be like in a room car uh
wallpapered with couch cushions in a
harness made of seat belts and that's a
great that's a great suspenseful scene
instead instead of like going for an
actual rape scene they they manage to
still kind of have its rape scene but
without the rape like it was a really
it's a it's a weirder morge I
challenging in a sense because if he's a
rapist we just go again like oh yeah
[ __ ] this guy he's yeah totally evil
that's that's awful and it's like it's
still totally evil and awful but you're
like wow your thought process is so much
different I thought it wouldn't have
made sense if you wanted a raper yeah
exactly exactly yeah it's like it's like
I can tell you thought about this I just
can't fathom yeah you know and that's a
scary like that is a true horror moment
because you're like this guy has a plan
I can't imagine how he came to it but he
sure seems to believe it that's a really
effective human horror moment a human
horror is the most scary to me
personally like that's the thing that
most it's like the perversions of the
mind things people can do to each other
and even if this movie gets heightened
man it still sells the sheer what the
[ __ ] terror of that situation though
totally and that's a left turn that
really does like you know it's like I
said this could have been its own movie
in its own way and it's like yeah that's
the guy's house you broke into his where
he was already having a day nobody even
really ends up a hero in this situation
yes everybody kind of got to get through
it like I love that Dylan Manette got
killed yeah I love that choice instead
of them getting together and being the
hero cuz cuz I first thought at first
it's like you already think he gets
killed yeah and then he's alive and
you're like yeah
yeah they like nobody's dead yeah and it
made that moment okay for me yeah okay
all right fine yeah I'll give it to you
and he doesn't die in a super
ceremonious way no you know like this is
one of those movies it's like once
you're gone you're gone there's no big
flashback Monta remember Alex anyway
dude that ending though okay okay like
the fact that he's okay the fact that
he's still alive
I can do I need to live with that but
the fact of how the cops were just like
there was just two robbers and you know
that's all I know
they're two bodies found in his basement
when when there's no did he did he get
rid of the one woman dad's the detail
I'm not sure and then he have like he
had a whole like dungeon down there with
trapeze and a vat of sperm there's a
whole thing going on down there what I
wonder is is just is simply this it
doesn't make it less of a flaw for the
movie perhaps but I'm wondering like
this will be an ongoing investigation
most likely you know like I'm sure
they'll find weird stuff later like this
is they show him just being carted out
of the house on a gurney they're like
he's gonna be fine they found two bodies
I do think that at least part of that
ending is a fittingly sinister because
it is like oh yeah the money's gone
they're just two robbers there this
guy's totally gonna be made out to be
here it's like that part of it really
worked for me the whole like this is
just a poor old blind you know veteran
and now you know these two guys but he
was able to defend himself and it's
gonna be okay it's like I can totally
see that newsroom spin it does at least
leave me with questions about well did
they poke around more and yeah what
happened - what happened - her body I
don't remember what happened her yeah I
just figured that they find him in his
dungeon they're probably gonna see that
he has this like Girl with the Dragon
Tattoo device setup or he's like [ __ ]
him grab anyone and maybe they'd be 1
million versus it's it that's the thing
that didn't that didn't bug me but I
would be curious now that you bring it
up it's like I would be curious to see
it again and see if it's still all winds
up cuz I think parts of it at least the
ideas are good because that is a fair
point
in terms of this is just them
discovering the situation and giving an
immediate reports that pop up to the
news usually first reports are not
exactly it's just the news reporting and
like this is how it exactly
yes it was just like a first discovery
kind of investigation yeah that she
happened to see and I guess an ad super
character and I mean she gotta get the
[ __ ] out because because it is about her
character and in that moment it's not so
much about Steven Lang's character it's
about how she has to live with the fact
that this man is still alive they have
that sort of like you can't really bring
it up to anybody like you wonder what
the implications are and and I do think
even though it is kind of vague cuz I
don't think they tell you how long after
I do think like she probably just left
that situation got her sister cleaned up
a little and they're gone
like yeah you know I gotta get out of
here now that was one things like this
was a movie that I thought earned its
its ending I was like it does end on a
bitter not bittersweet surround word but
it does end on like a note but with them
going off like I was like huh it's a
nice reward for the end of all this you
know be really unexpected in Ocean's
Twelve kind of sequel oh yeah
all right geez spends most of the money
in California Stephen Lang shows up and
she's like oh [ __ ] you found me
and Stevens Lang's like you have one
week to give me back my million so Dylan
Manette comes back we have no
explanation as to why he lives though
then in don't breathe three he blows all
that money and he needs to like work
alright yeah don't breathe you really
like this movie yeah describe the real
rejects check out our non-spoiler review
and all the jon stuff it's all in the
description box please don't let me to
say have you been to this far in the
video you've probably been here before
you know what to do